der Online-Riese Amazon eines von 20
Logistikzentren lässt der Konzern in
seinen Hallen weiterhin massenhaft neue
waren und funktionstüchtigere Touren in
den Müll wandern frontal hat gemeinsam
mit dem Business Insider über Monate
hinweg Amazon Beschäftigte an
unterschiedlichen Standorten getroffen
weil sie ihre Jobs riskieren reden sie
anonym
wir haben eigentlich fast alles was bei
Amazon verkauft wird bei uns auch in der
vernichtungsware es blutet einem schon
das Herz diese Fotos haben sie heimlich
gemacht die Bilder zeigen was in die
Vernichtung gehen soll Solarleuchten
Lampen
Tonerkartuschen und Keyboards in großen
Mengen erzählen die Beschäftigten es ist
nicht palettenweise es ist lkw-weise in
jedem Lager in jedem Lager
ich schätze zum Großteil Neuware die da
vernichtet wird jetzt hatten wir zwei
Paletten Babydecken ich weiß nicht was
damit falsch war die waren
originalverpackt so eine Babydecke hat
einen Wert von ca 45 bis 60 Euro der
Unmut der Amazon Beschäftigten ist groß
immer wieder wenden Sie sich an die
Gewerkschaft Verdi
wir finden das ist ein Skandal zum eine
aus umwelttechnischen Gründen das nicht
nachvollziehen können aber auch mit
Blick darauf das Ressourcen einfach
knapper werden Rückblick 2018 hatte
frontal erstmals über die Vernichtung
von Neuwaren und Retouren in großem Stil
bei Amazon berichtet
wird eigentlich alles was nicht mehr
nicht und nagelfest ist Fernseher Beamer
Rasenmäher Kühlschränke wie funktioniert
dieses vernichten
Presse auf Ware reinpresse zu die
Bundesregierung hatte daraufhin 2020 das
Kreislaufwirtschaftsgesetz geändert die
Obhutspflicht eingeführt Obhutspflicht
gibt es zum ersten Mal eine gesetzliche
Grundlage um eben die Vernichtung von
Retouren und warenüberhängen endlich
zurückzudrängen neue Produkte sollten
nicht mehr auf der Müllhalde enden die
Obhutspflicht dafür sorgen dass
Hersteller und Händler ihre Waren
gebrauchstauglich halten
dies sind aktuelle Bilder fotografiert
von Amazon Beschäftigten offenbar greift
das Gesetz nicht eine Halle mit
Containern randvoll mit Ware die
vernichtet werden soll
Tonerkartuschen Hoverboards und
Kettensägen
da gibt es kleine Artikel die wir
vernichten aber auch Sachen die im
Haushalt gebraucht werden Töpfe zum
Beispiel oder Autofelgen ganz viel aus
dem Sortiment was bei Amazon verkauft
wird kommt bei uns auch in die
Vernichtung
neuer Laptop Kopfhörer werden
weggeschmissen wenn man das sieht als
normaler Mitarbeiter vergleicht was da
weggeschmissen wird mit dem was man
verdient pro Stunde dann ist das schon
gewaltig
wir stehen manchmal davor und schütteln
einfach nur den Kopf warum wird das
weggeschmissen
diese internen amazonlisten wurden
Greenpeace zugespielt frontal hat die
120 Seiten ausgewertet sie zeigen welche
Mengen Amazon in Deutschland und anderen
europäischen Ländern recycelt und
vernichtet allein in Deutschland soll
das Unternehmen demnach in rund
eineinhalb Jahren nur in der Gruppe
product verschiedenes knapp
1.840 Tonnen weggeworfen haben
vernichtet wird weiter in jedem Fall es
ist nicht erkennbar dass es irgendwelche
Veränderungen gibt das einzige was sich
geändert hat ist die Bezeichnung an
manchen Standorten heißt es Aufbereitung
oder remove Amazon vermeidet das Wort
destroyed zerstören und dem ganzen einem
besseren Namen zu geben
wir zeigen die Fotos Viola Wohlgemuth
von Greenpeace seit Jahren kämpft sie
gegen Ressourcenverschwendung
ja ich würde ja gerne sagen ich bin
erschrocken und geschockt leider
bestätigt es genau das was wir immer
wieder von Amazon sehen die Praktiken
das vernichtens von neu waren und von
retourenscheinen auch auf ihren Bildern
auf den verschiedenen Standorten von
Amazon halt überall gleich Stadt zu
finden und es ist einfach so ein hohen
wenn ich dann sehe das einzige was ich
anscheinend geändert hat ist es heißt
jetzt nicht mehr die destroy Paletten es
sind jetzt die remove Paletten und das
war's wie kann es sein dass so ein
Konzern das ist ihm erlaubt wird solche
endlichen Ressourcen einfach zu
vernichten frontal fragt bei Amazon nach
werden weiterhin unverkaufte neu waren
und Retouren in großem Umfang vernichtet
das Unternehmen teilt mit weniger als
ein Prozent der Amazon eigenen Produkte
werde entsorgt Recycling inbegriffen
mehr als die Hälfte der weltweit bei
Amazon verkauften Produkte stammen von
unabhängigen Partnerunternehmen Zitat
da die zurückgesendeten Produkte nicht
uns gehören liegt es an den
Verkaufspartnern zu entscheiden was mit
den wahren geschieht
das große Problem sehe ich darin dass
man sich dahinter versteckt das ist
alles drittanbieterware als
marktbeherrschender Spieler könnte
Amazon die Regeln auch anders aufstellen
und prinzipiell sagen wenn ihr Ware
nicht mehr benötigt dann wird sie immer
gespendet Amazon teilt weiter mit das
Unternehmen halte sich ein jegliche
gesetzlichen Pflichten Zitat
der Großteil der retournierten Produkte
wird wieder in den Verkauf gebracht
damit andere Kundinnen es kaufen können
außerdem werde zurückgegebene Kleidung
recycelt so ein Recycling betreibt die
Firma retextil greenpeace hat in das
Unternehmen einen undercover-studenten
eingeschläust unter dem Vorwand einer
Masterarbeit hat er sich umgeschaut dort
hat er eben eindeutig gesehen dass dort
Textilien die ankommen die noch gut sind
zerschnitten werden damit sie und das
wurde ihm auch ganz klar gesagt eben
nicht mehr in den Umlauf kommen können
also Firmen wollen wirklich dass Ihre
Ware zum Beispiel nicht auf den
Zweitmarkt kommen dass ihr so nicht als
secondhand verkauft wird sondern sie
nehmen es lieber im Kauf dass sie extra
dafür zahlen dass händisch diese Ware
zerstört wird bevor sie dann ins
Recycling geht
der angebliche student will wissen warum
die Textilien zerschnitten wurden
retextil antwortet ihm wir schneiden die
Ware ein um auszuschließen das auf
welchem Weg auch immer die Ware wieder
irgendwo zum Verkauf auftaucht im
schlimmsten Fall auf Flohmärkten
frontal konfrontiert retextil keine
Antwort wir Fragen zu der zerschnittenen
Kleidung nach bei Amazon schriftlich
heißt es Zitat
wir geben unverkaufte oder
zurückgegebene Modeartikel an
Recyclingunternehmen weiter die dann
entscheiden wie sie die Lebensdauer der
Stoffe am besten verlängern können
Greenpeace hält dagegen Amazon
verschwende nach wie vor unnötig
Ressourcen nicht nur bei Kleidung
das ist eben leider die traurige
Wahrheit wir sehen dass man mit der
Vernichtung von Neuwahlen mit der
Vernichtung von Textilien einfach Geld
machen kann und dass diese Prozedere
eigentlich ja diese tägliche Katastrophe
die wir eigentlich sehen einfach
weiterläuft jeden Tag und von der
Bundesregierung hier eben nicht
eingeschritten wird wir fragen nach im
Bundesministerium für Umwelt ein
Interview gibt es nicht die Regierung
scheint stolz auf das Gesetz antwortet
schriftlich Zitat
allein die Tatsache dass die
Obhutspflicht im deutschen
Kreislaufwirtschaftsgesetz steht hat
schon jetzt einige Unternehmen zum
Umdenken gebracht
viele Amazon Beschäftigte kritisieren
das Gesetz nutze nichts meiner Meinung
nach liegt das daran dass die Gesetze
nicht umgesetzt werden das niemand da
ist der Amazon kontrolliert und auf die
Finger schaut also ich habe noch nie
erlebt dass jemand da war und die
vernichtungstonnen aufgemacht hat und
reingeschaut hat und sich hat zeigen
lassen was da vernichtet wird und sich
auch hat begründen lassen warum das
vernichtet wird
fest steht die Bundesregierung hat
bisher nicht dafür gesorgt dass Verstöße
gegen das Kreislaufwirtschaftsgesetz
geahndet werden können das
Bundesumweltministerium räumt ein Zitat
da derzeit keine Rechtsverordnung zur
Umsetzung der Obhutspflicht existiert
kann bei einer warenvernichtung kein
Bußgeld erhoben werden
diese Bilder müssen dazu führen dass
Amazon Bußgelder bekommen das muss klar
sein es muss so wehtun das Amazon
aufhört zu vernichten sonst ist dieses
Gesetz ein Papiertiger der wirklich das
Papier nicht wert ist auf dem es
geschrieben ist
mangelnde Kontrollen und keine Bußgelder
so enden weiterhin massenhaft Retouren
und Neuwagen auf dem Müll